This is the Speed Dialer
app where you are able
to call, email,
WhatsApp, look at the company.
Here on the top you
can add your lead sheets
or they are inserted directly
from the MCP.
The leads for each user
or sales rep.
You can add your sales
script here
and the objection handling here
and then once you add
them while you're on the
call you can just click
on it and read it
when you speak to someone
same as goes for the
objection handling
it's quite straightforward now
when you call
each user has different numbers
for this user specifically he
can call from a US
West number
from a US East number
it's plus 1202 this one
is plus 1505 and from
Austria number and an Israeli
number
the the person receives the
call will receive
the call depending or on
which number I choose to
call from
once I do the call
I'm able to see my
recent calls
you download them to see
the transcript of each one
and down here if I
have any note I can
write it down
and then edit directly
now if you've ever been
to sales you probably know
this is very convenient that
you can use it from
your phone or from the
laptop it's just super relevant
to today's where people are
working remotely they can do
their call calling
or calling to their existing
leads from anywhere